General entrepreneur advice?
>> Yep.
>> My favorite question so far.
[LAUGH] Just be passionate.
Understand what it is you want and
why you're doing this thing.
Because if you don't, if you're chasing
something or following someone else's
advice, you are living what they want,
not what you want.
The best way to succeed that
I found is to follow that
thing that is important to you and
knowing what's important to you is
actually a big challenge,
a lot of people don't know.
There's a few other
things I can add to this.
One is, my dream was always
to come to California and
work for one of the largest,
most influential companies in the area.
I've had this dream since I read
Microserf's when I was 12 and
it took 20 odd years before that
actually happened but it did happen.
But through the process of just
always focusing on that's my goal and
everything that I'm going to do
is somehow going to get me there.
All the businesses that I started,
all the business partners and
relationships I built and communities
that I was involved in through all
the businesses that I ran, I was always
looking to come specifically here.
On the flip side of that,
something I would advise all
entrepreneurs to be aware of especially
in the startup scene, is that
startups are seen as a product now.
They are a commodity in and
out of themselves.
There is an entire
industry that is built up
around selling things to startups and
selling the concept of startups.
Don't believe the hype.
Do not waste your time going
to stupid conferences for
silly awards that mean
nothing to your business.
Always focus on your core values and
what your business means to you and
why it's valuable.